God doesn't love me
not like I out last Tuesday I'll commit
Minh to its core conceit is
simultaneously its greatest strength and
its greatest weakness like the original
which helped popularize first-person
survival war when it launched in 2013
outlast to cast you as a hapless
everyman with zero fighting skills and
no tools beyond a camcorder your only
option would confront it with grotesque
bloodthirsty murderers is to run and
hide as a result every snapping twig
every distance screaming every room some
corpse grips you with gear even more
tightly than it might if you actually
had a way to defend yourself
[Music]
but this also means the core gameplay
cannot evolve as you progress the chase
sequences that you survive at the start
are essentially identical to the
situation's you encounter near the end
there aren't many new mechanics or
scenarios to keep the intervening hours
feeling varied and engaging the game's
most harrowing moments those sequences
where you're spotted by an enemy and
must flee to safety
frequently devolve into trial and error
tedium almost invariably these chases
are scripted meaning you must get from
point A to a specific point B as quickly
as possible problem is point B is rarely
obvious it might be a tiny opening you
have to crawl through or a bookcase you
have to move but you only have a few
seconds to figure it out before your
pursuers catch up and kill you and when
you die you're forced to replay most of
the chase in order to return to the
apparent dead end where you got stuck at
that point the game stops being scary
and simply becomes frustrating this was
occasionally an issue in the first game
as well but you often had more freedom
and could play more strategically in
outlast 2 you generally just need to run
from whatever's directly behind you and
hope you figure out the one correct path
as you go at least when you do stay on
track it's unbelievably intense and
exhilarating the fact that the game
excels if delivering sudden bursts of
panic keeps your nerves on edge at all
times you never quite know when hell is
gonna break loose again but you always
know it's coming
really tension is what outlast 2 does
best its gameplay may stumble but you're
always deeply inescapably immersed in
its atmosphere in place of the first
games mental asylum new protagonist
Blake Langerman finds himself lost in
the Arizona desert surrounded by
religious zealots and fetid corpses
though you'll endure a wide variety of
environments desecration follows you
everywhere
and while the visuals pack plenty of
unsettling details the sound design is
some of the best in horror game history
from the jagged unnerving score to the
harsh whispers that seem to come from
all directions
outlast 2's audio is the single biggest
contributor to its remarkable sense of
foreboding
all of these scare tactics get in your
head and in a way deep in those skin
crawling lols between the adrenaline
pumping chases when you're utterly
convinced some new [ __ ] just waiting
to rip your throat out even just
exploring for camera batteries suddenly
feels like a harrowing trial and you'll
need those batteries just as before your
camera's night vision allows you to see
in the dark and the new directional mic
lets you loosely track enemies through
walls however both of these comforts
drain your batteries at an alarming rate
especially in higher difficulty settings
you can keep night-vision on even when
you run out of juice but your screen
starts to flicker and the camera can't
focus
it's almost scarier than being totally
blind so it's important to expend your
battery power strategically I never had
a problem finding batteries on normal
but higher difficulty settings turn this
aspect of the experience into a
legitimate challenge even if you're
stocked up on batteries though there's
another reason to brave exploration
journal entries as with the original
game there's no traditional story arc
with a beginning middle and end instead
you're given a goal in this case to save
your missing wife and bad stuff happens
to you as you pursue that goal the only
way to understand your situation is to
gather information from for example
suicide notes and deranged gospel
excerpts
the writing is strong throughout but
outlast 2 is primary narrative relies
too heavily on trite horror tropes but
there is another side outlast 2 story as
you progress blake starts to experience
hallucinations that seem to depict a
traumatic childhood event they reveal
new details at exactly the right pace
providing subtle devastating hints
without spelling everything out it
hooked me early compelled me through the
campaign and eventually delivered an
emotional payoff all while tying
together both halves of the game through
shared themes of guilt abandonment and
the exploitation of faith altogether
Blake's hallucinations proved to be one
of the game's strongest elements in
truth outlasts no weapons formula worked
better as a shorter experience stretched
over twice the length of the original
game outlast 2's gameplay starts to wear
thin especially since too many of its
scripted chases funnel you down preset
paths at the same time however I admire
its purity and to an extent I'm willing
to accept its shortcomings for the sake
of true survival horror the campaign is
scary from start to finish and delivers
on its promise of unrelenting terror in
part because it never allows you to
fight back the atmosphere and sound
design are expertly crafted and Blake's
hallucinations elevate the game's story
above that of the first but it
unquestionably provides a more polished
version of the same idea